[Music]
did you hear the latest no bill clinton
bill clinton now says he wishes he had
supported gay marriage back when he was
president
yeah that's what he said
yeah
clinton said at the time he was too busy
campaigning for open marriage
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm miming him in a hot tub
you can only fight one fight at a time
you got to take your time
did you hear what rush limbaugh said
rush limbaugh said that lesbians don't
have to worry about their appearance so
they're free to get fat
then moments later rush limbaugh
officially came out as a lesbian
i always knew didn't you know
i always suspected yeah i had a sense a
uh
a new poll came out shows that 64 of new
jersey residents don't care about
governor chris christie's weight 64
percent that nice yeah of course that's
mostly because governor chris christie
is
64
of new jersey he accounts
i like that all right
the crowd's like oh yeah okay here
nicely done huh that joke was my gift to
you on your wedding
[Laughter]
so romantic they got a chris christie
fat joke yeah they can tell their
children about it someday
another member of seal team six has come
forward to say that bin laden was
unarmed when he was shot
yeah
i think i speak for everyone when i say
and
[Applause]
[Music]
are we going somewhere with this
uh parts of the berlin wall have been
removed despite a protest led by david
hasselhoff
that's true
yeah the thick crumbling structure that
didn't last very long into the 90s said
the wall shouldn't be removed
folks i'll tell you why that's funny
you thought i was talking about the wall
but i was talking about david hasselhoff
see
once i explained it it was hilarious
they just need a little help sometimes
sure yeah you know what i'm throwing
that joke in as a wedding kid
you get a governor chris christie joke
and that horrible horrible berlin wall
david hasselhoff joke
you should probably include a gift
receipt on both of them
oh in case they want to return yeah yeah
them i wish i had a return policy on
this job
what if every night i was like yeah no
no i'm not going with that one
i want my money back
hey gang check this out
victoria's secret is under fire for
targeting youth with its new slogan
bright young things
yeah yeah however it's still a lot
better than its previous slogan the
catalog for horny men with no internet
that's what it is
[Applause]
[Music]
why did i mime it no reason
apologies all around that's another one
for you guys that's three jokes
three jokes
it's getting better for you all the time
i haven't given you a good one yet amen
a man has won an eight thousand dollar
settlement from disneyland after he got
stuck on their it's a small world ride
yeah the man said he'll use the money to
cut out the part of his brain that won't
stop playing it's a small world after
all it's right here it has to go
new study just came out found that
herpes may lead to memory loss
which is too bad because the only upside
to having herpes is fondly remembering
how you got it
it's really the only upside
i'm remembering it way too fondly